bouton et s'apprête eu la preuve tu leur
avec l'aide du président du tribunal de
grande instance de blois
les élèves se préparent à jouer leur
rôle qu'il travaille depuis deux mois
avec leur professeur de français et
d'histoire que je
je donne le verdict que j'interroge les
témoins les prévenus oui puis au début
s'explique les affaires inspiré
d'audience réel les dialogues ont été
écrits par les enseignants et les élèves
qui se sont parfaitement approprié leur
rôle lui comme d'habitude pour le saisir
dans les bras pour le calmer mais je
n'en ai pas eu le temps
j'ai pris un coup de poing dans
l'objectif de ce procès la prévention
ces adolescents sont désormais
sensibilisés à la problématique des
violences domestiques
mais comme m'a dit il depuis toujours
que vous faites et il me battait me
tirer cheveux me rabaisser c'était dire
quand il s'énervait faut en parler déjà
et qu'il faut pas le laisser faire et il
faut pas croire que c'est notre faute
c'est pas nous passons de passes carbone
co c'est ne pas reproduire ou produire
ses effets de violence mais aussi d'être
conscient que la violence elle n'est pas
normal elle doit être dénoncé ce procès
fictif a suscité des vocations de
juriste chez certains adolescents avocat
procureur ils ont appris à connaître une
justice méconnu quant aux violences
domestiques tous nous l'ont assuré s'ils
y sont confrontés désormais ils
parleront